esta vez tengo dos expresiones
diferentes y quiero tomar la derivada de
ambas pero antes de resolverlas juntos
me gustaría que pausar es el vídeo y que
pensara en cómo encontrar la derivada de
esta expresión y si ese procedimiento
sería el mismo o diferente al tomar esta
otra derivada la clave no es resolver
toda la derivada sino pensar sobre cómo
identificar la estrategia que debes usar
ok primero vamos a abordar esta derivada
y la clave para trabajar con una
expresión compleja como estas dos es ver
la estructura completa de la expresión
así que una forma de pensarlo es
fijarnos en los detalles del exterior
antes que los detalles del interior y si
nos fijamos en el exterior tenemos el
seno de algo el seno de algo que estoy
indicando en color rosa así que en la
parte exterior podemos ver este seno de
esto que está dentro es parecido a tener
algo grande elevado a un cierto
exponente o no sé en este caso es algo
grande dentro de una función
trigonométricas
y si tienes una situación de este estilo
es una buena señal de que debemos
utilizar la regla de la cadena así que
déjame ponerlo vamos a utilizar la regla
de la cadena rc para hablar de la regla
de la cadena y cómo podemos aplicarla
bueno vamos a tomar la derivada de lo de
afuera con respecto a lo de adentro por
la derivada de lo de adentro con
respecto a x así que podemos escribirlo
como la derivada con respecto a ese
álbum a este algo que voy a escribir con
este círculo rosa que representa todo lo
que tengo adentro de este círculo rosa
ok la derivada con respecto a ese algo
del seno de ese algo ni siquiera es
necesario pensar en que haya dentro de
ese algo ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por la derivada con respecto a x de ese
algo esto es simplemente aplicar la
regla de la cadena y es que no importa
que tengas dentro de este círculo rosa
podrían ser raíces cuadradas o
logaritmos o lo que sea todo lo que este
contenido
de este seno lo voy a mover a este paso
es decir la derivada con respecto a ese
algo del seno de ese algo por la
derivada con respecto x de ese algo
ahora bueno en este caso particular que
es ese algo bueno esta primera parte que
pondré de color anaranjado simplemente
va a ser la derivada del seno que es el
coseno de y bueno tengo adentro x
cuadrada más 5 esto que multiplica al
coseno de x que observa es lo que tengo
adentro de este círculo de rosa bien y
déjame cerrar el coseno ok por la
derivada con respecto x del álbum que
eran x cuadrada más 5 que multiplica al
coseno de x ok y ahora déjame cerrar mis
corchetes
y claro que todavía no he acabado aquí
me hace falta hacer esta derivada con
respecto a x y por aquí si vemos la
estructura te vas a dar cuenta de que
tenemos dos expresiones multiplicadas
una por la otra esta vez no tenemos una
única gran
presión aplicada a una entrada como fue
en un principio la función será o pudo
haber sido la función coseno o alguna
gran expresión elevado a un cierto
exponente o lo que sea aquí simplemente
tengo dos expresiones multiplicadas
déjame señalar las tengo esta expresión
que multiplica a esta otra expresión así
que si sólo tengo dos expresiones que se
multiplican entre sí esa es una buena
pista de que debemos usar la regla del
producto y puedo seguir trabajando esta
derivada hasta terminarla pero te voy a
encargar que lo hagas la idea de este
vídeo es pensar más en las estrategias
detrás de estas derivadas y cómo
reconocerlas hoy así que es momento de
pensar en el otro ejemplo esto se parece
más a este segundo paso de mi primer
ejemplo aquí no tengo el seno aplicado a
una gran expresión o una gran expresión
elevada a un cierto exponente o lo que
sea en este caso tengo el producto de
dos expresiones tenemos dos expresiones
que están multiplicadas entre sí
tengo esta expresión que multiplica a
esta otra expresión y entonces mi
cerebro dicen como tengo la derivada de
dos expresiones que se están
multiplicando esa es una buena pista
para aplicar la regla del producto si
tuviera una expresión dividida entre
otra expresión bueno usaría la regla del
cociente pero en este caso va a ser la
regla del producto y bueno la regla del
producto me dice que tendrá que tomar la
derivada con respecto a x de la primera
expresión que es esta expresión en
anaranjado por la segunda expresión y a
esto sumarle la primera expresión tal
cual está por la derivada con respecto a
x de la segunda expresión y una vez más
simplemente estoy utilizando la regla
del producto 10 y puedes simplemente
sustituir el seno de x cuadrada + 5 por
este círculo anaranjado el coseno de x
por este círculo de azul pero lo más
importante y el punto aquí es que
abordamos esta derivada usando la regla
del producto así que espero que esto te
sirva para identificar la estructura de
las expresiones y saber cuándo puedes
utilizar la regla de la cadena y en este
caso después la regla del producto o en
este caso que utilizamos la regla del
producto y bueno observa una vez que
hagas esto todavía no hemos acabado para
obtener esta derivada tendrías que
utilizar la regla de la cadena y seguir
hasta que no tengas más derivadas que
tomar bueno eso es todo en este vídeo
hasta el siguiente